[Music]
but since we have made reference to the
silly ins both those in the Caucasus and
those who face northwards come then come
let us interrupt our history and present
like an intercalated narrative the
events which attended these very great
nations during these times when summer
had arrived in this particular year he
who is celebrated by the Turks as char
gang in the east dispatched ambassadors
to the Emperor Maurice he composed a
letter and described it in victory
praises to the king of the Romans the
Chagin the great lord of seven races and
master of seven zones of the world for
this very Chagin had in fact outfought
the leader of the nation of the abba
deli and enslaved the avon nation so
when the ava's had been defeated some of
them made their escape to those who
inhabit Towe gassed
taou gassed is a famous city which is a
total of 1500 miles distant from those
who are called Turks and which borders
on the Indians the barbarians who abode
near Talgarth are a very brave and
numerous nation and without rival in
size among the nations of the world
others of the ava's who declined to
humble a fortune because of their defeat
came to those who are called Mochrie
this nation is the closest neighbor to
the men of Tao gassed it has great might
in battle
both because of its daily practice of
drill and because of endurance of spirit
in danger and so after concluding the
Civil War the Chagin of the Turks
managed to first prosperously while he
made an agreement with the men of Tao
just so that he might bring in secure
peace from all sides and make his rule
unchallenged
the regional commander of Tao gust is
called tae-san which signifies son of
God in the Greek tongue the realm of Tao
best is not troubled by discord for
lineage provides them with the selection
of their leader statues are the cult of
this nation the laws are just and their
life is full of discretion they have a
custom which resembles law that males
should never embellish themselves with
gold adornment even though they have
become owners of a great abundance of
silver and gold as a result of their
large and advantageous trading
a river divides this tau gust once long
ago the river was interposed between two
great two nations who were mutually
hostile the dress of one was black and
the other scarlet hewed then in our
times while maurice was in possession of
the roman scepters the black-robed
nation crossed the river and joined
battle with those wearing the red
clothing next having gained victory it
became master of the whole Dominion this
tower gust in fact the barbarians say
was founded by the Macedonian
Alexander when he enslaved to the
bactrian sand saga Durrani and burned 12
Myriad's of barbarians in this city the
rulers wives have carriages made of gold
each of which is drawn by one book
lavishly decorated with gold and
precious stones and even the auxins
reins are gold inlaid and so the man who
was assumed the Dominion of Tao ggest
used to pass the night with seven
hundred women the wives of the nobility
of Tao gassed used silver carriages
there is a report that Alexander also
founded another City a few miles away
which the barbarians named Choob Dan and
that when the leader dies he is mourned
forever by his wives who have their
heads shaved and who wear black clothing
and that is the custom for these women
never to leave the tomb chop Dan is
divided by two great rivers whose banks
nod so to speak with cypresses the
nation has many elephants they associate
in trade with the Indians and they say
that these Indians who faced the
northern regions are actually born white
the worms from which come the CEREC
threads are possessed by the said nation
in a very great number and are in turn
possessed of varied color the barbarians
eagerly practice the
three of the said creatures
you
[Music]
[Applause]